we're gonna dig a bit deeper into the
geometry symmetries okay now like I said
you already know some okay I'm you know
about reflection there's another reflect
name for reflective simchas they don't
know what it is that's an element it
talks about when you reflect something
right you generally have to reflect
across a line like this that's a line of
symmetry or the line that has a special
name is called an axis of symmetry right
so we often call this line symmetry okay
hopefully that's that's a bit you've led
this before now rotation it has a
similar name to by incisions you never
know what it is just like it it's not
like that well apart from rotational
symmetry like ah yeah everything it's
costly often called point symmetry okay
because way you reflect your request for
UEFA cups of wine right when you rotate
you don't rotate the round align you
rotate around a point Syrian yes so in
fact this is often called that the
process of doing a rotation is often
also called a central inversion that's
that inverse language that you're
talking about
okay and I didn't even talk about it I
could've I didn't even talk about
functional symmetry you know for
instance everyone gets that there's some
kind of balance between something like
say y equals x squared and y equals the
square root of x right we call those
investors there's a functional symmetry
there anyway pairs decide okay now these
are interesting is a really cool okay
and you're gonna need your rulers here
and in fact you're gonna need like a
quite a good ruler which has like
centimeter markings on it and that kind
of thing
rotations are hard to do it quite hard
so you need practice and stuff like that
okay but you can actually do point
symmetry without any angles whatsoever
joy yourself a shape any shape you like
I'm gonna do some
like he's a shame okay you can join
yourself a shape but for the sake of
what we're about to illustrate it'll
help you it's not too complicated and
will also help if it's got some
well-defined vertices on it corners a
rule though you'll definitely need a
rule for this I'm only using straight
lines because it's just gonna be easier
for me yeah you're like a big space you
probably need like the width of your
page it kind of depends on what you do
in a second okay all right now point
symmetry right just like I have mine
symmetry knees aligned points in she's
gonna need a point so I'm gonna pick a
point and I can put it anywhere I like
for this one I'm gonna put it yeah
that'll do okay now with your ruler
another comma here we go with your ruler
what I want you to do is I've got five
points yeah I've just drawn up a
Pentagon okay I'm gonna take each of the
five points and I'm going to go to this
central point and then go further the
same distance example okay
I don't have a straight nothing here but
I'm gonna 30 centimeter almost two
things I'm gonna do so here's my first
point and I'm going to put my ruler
across here okay now for instance
suppose on your page the distance from
here to the point I'm reflecting across
suppose it was two centimeters okay so
what should take that - Sammis and go
another two centimeters over here it's
you know so it's gonna go across like
that right now you want to repeat this
process for all of your other points
you're gonna get something like let's
just try this out this one's gonna go
down here this one's gonna go
and lastly okay sir
after reflecting that's all I'm doing
here I'm reflecting across a point right
each one goes in that same distance okay
what you get at the other end if you
rejoin everything should be well it
should be symmetrical right now here's
what's interesting right we reflected
but this is not reflectional symmetry
right it's not across a line we didn't
reflect across a line we reflected
across a point and the other way you
could have done this is by spinning this
around it's actually rotational symmetry
but we didn't rotate anything it's a bit
funny okay so we've got line symmetry
we've got point symmetry I can't get
away from discussing geometrics injuries
without talking about helical symmetry
now no you shouldn't you should climb to
recognize it number one because the word
is this a familiar word hidden in here
and number two because each and every
one of you are actually carrying around
a helical symmetry with you everywhere
you go in fact you're carrying hundreds
and hundreds of kilometers of helical
symmetry around I wonder if that's
enough of a clue what do you think's the
word underneath helical that where it
comes from very close it comes from the
word
helix helix right so that's the word
comes from the Greek word for a twist or
spin or spiral okay so I suppose you
could call it spiral symmetry okay yes
of course right you're on your
chromosomes now this is just one helix
okay but your your DNA is not a single
helix is it it's a it's a double helix
that's exactly right so I can't draw it
you can go look up a pitch shot okay I
did them both the same way that's why
yeah I should twist from this direction
should know yeah that's better
it's just looking like a spiral Messier
off anyway okay see look at Syria now
the reason why you haven't heard about
this so much is because 117 points in
retreat are both on a plane and they're
really easy to understand so that's a 2d
and that's 2d but helical symmetry it
needs another dimension it's 3d okay
now even though it's a 3d you can make
it easily enough with something 2d so
here's what I would do you can take a
plane right and if you cut it up
properly okay and you introduce another
dimension to it a vertical one then you
get a shape with helical symmetry it's
very simple to make